Hmmm yes wake up
500mm
blood subordinates every time
I can do this because of special blood 0 I got
pulled out
Good morning
I'll give you an example of donating blood at all in the field This game is
Sambridge played by Norman Reedus
Yes
Claire  It's a
game to change, but
of course Norman plays the cold in the cut
scene.During the game, I'm
rather myself, and the
third part is Norman.
I say
that it synchronizes with the player, but I'm still
operating
it, so this is not the case. I operate the camera,
so I look at the Sam Noh board.
It's a small break to play 3 buttons.
Well, there is a place to go a little, but I'm going to take a
rest with an adventure used voice and play a little mountain bottle
, so I'm playing the
camera for 8 days now.
I want to go, I'm
finally coming in, because I have to order
why I'm the soul,
I'm not letting him do that, I'm operating the camera
.
When
I see him, he reacts to various things, for
example, 2 I'm
taking a tremendous number of motions,
so I'm doing it, and I'm doing
it.  I shot it in a gray place where my brain burns,
so it's time
to do it. It's a cool role, but here
you can see Norman's cute place that you haven't seen so much,
for example, at your feet.
I think I'm going to zoom in. I think
there's a tremendous amount of gimmicks
. I'm enjoying it slowly.
For example, zooming in the crotch.
Please send me a stop sound.
Please
take a shower
. I'd like to make a report. Yes, it's true. Raise your middle finger here.
But today I'm going home because it's a Tokyo game show
.
Thank you for your concern.
Mokkai Shokudo
Well, there's something like this.
Peace players are in a mode where they move the camera
.
It's a
band that tells you to go to the washroom. The
washbasin ost
shark is different
. Here in the washroom, there are various
motions, so if you defeat it with an
analog stick, it will come out.
Thank
you for laughing. I don't laugh.
I'm
pretty
different. Then I feel a little different.
Akane.
I can press the shutter,
so I'll take the face of my favorite Sam.
It's the
player's situation that comes out, but
the number of good hands will change depending on this.
Please come in.
What is it now?
Oh,
Kondo line score If you can take the head there,
I don't know what it is with this nova ad lib,
but when
I make such a set, it's all done
from morning till night.
I like this one, but I
don't see a very bad feeling, so
let's go back a little
.
I winked that I wanted to take a sour,
but it's okay. If I
say something wrong, it will do something.
Yes, I had a shower the other day
, so
that person has a toilet with that unit bath
.  It's said that the shower
was seen the other day, but
that
stencil is attached to the body, isn't it? Because it's a wasteland person
's handprint
, if you go out with a game over or that rag, you will go to Ana and come back,
but
depending on the player
It will change.
Let's go to the bathroom for a while.
[Music] It's a
small one.
This is the one that has accumulated in that assault. The
amount will change.
This is me, this is hematuria.
I'm going to use it as a weapon. Iron is a particularly powerful weapon because it's finished a while ago
.
Then, the next
7 and
the bigger ones
will be sold.
]
What is the sound of the microphone
? I was able to do both chart shows myself. I was doing my best, but
I also listen
to Catcher Geiyama, so when I come out here, I
can have 2 private boxes, so
it's a delicate feeling automatically.  That kind of
thing is also a rate, isn't it? That bell is really that
unusual constitution, so I understand that there is money, blood, and
body fluids
to live in bt,
so let's fight with it here.
There's
something like that mom, but I
've only said one, but this is
so-called, isn't
it?
Fast Travel
That open world.
I
'm going to see 3 of them.
It's said that it's a little more beautiful, but this is that
equipment, so it's completely popular
with the weapon equipment that I have or the weapon that I can
make with a printer.
No,
this will be reflected in the sky in the end.
That's right,
this Undergaia is the best house on that back. This is
bad road name.
Then, let's go to a big store
[Music
] Well, it's not at all from the left side,
right
? Zoom in a little and this is a good rotation
. This is that hematuria.
Well, this is a beer or a
terrorist
.
It
's a guy who used a blood grenade-sama's house. This is a
Gazer catcher o
Well, you can fight something
.
Is in  Is there an explanation
written? Hey, it looks like it's a little pulled. Well,
there's not much Buddhism yet. The top white guy.
The tied aura is the one
that comes out now. I often see it, but
the bottom one is the
assault rifle. Well, this is a
terrorist beer
.  It's all orange Urasaki
Blue
Yellow or Kana Ding This is the
image of that high school. It's more
like an angry blue color rather than a weapon
.
Next is a little bb,
so let's go
. It's easy. It's a chance to get along here
.
Yes, do you love me a little?
[Music]
me
nd
me ana
[Music]
read me
Boo Boo
Bait e-chan Noodle
baby Yes  If you do this kind of thing, you can get to
know each other intimately
.
[Music]
Have you been on the stage for many years? Yes, the app is about to
sell. Drag f
Ah,
let's go this time.
Defan Yes, like this
[Music]
Yes, next
time I can see the backpack, but I can customize
it. Actually, let's do it.
Well, it's okay as it is, but the
strike is the weapon prime minister.  All of them will be luggage,
so if you attach a pouch here, you
can carry more, so let's do it a little.
Grenade pouch will increase this more. You
can rotate the pouch that gives
you a net or lay it out yourself
.  You can buy as much as you can,
so if you lay it out yourself
and attach only the grenade pouch, you will have a
tremendous number.
There is an access person, and on
the left I can only remember two or two, but
I'm a grenade, and I
'll put a lot of windmills on it.
There is such a statute of limitations, but if you
meet various people or do various things, you can
get this.
You don't know the shaven in the Imperial City right now
.
If you hang it the night before, you can
make something like a curse that it may not rain,
right?
Let's
put on this a
little.  It will decrease.
It's not before curing,
so let's write a little color.
Actually, there will be more colors.
It's only now, but fluorescent colors are
popular, but if there is a deficit at the end of the march, it will be
red.  If you
take a look at it,
Manakana is fashionable.
This is the decision. Ah
, it's red when you make a decision with interesting soccer.
The person who rides on the table changes depending on the +,
but today
it's like
this, so take it off Lee This
is a worm I like the progel I ate in the game
I'm the one brought by Fragile
.  Let's eat No, if you eat a
lot of beaters, the
number of railroads will increase. Let's go first. I'll eat
Mager Today this morning
.
[Music] Hmm
ame I'd like another one.
Teru
This is that Norma's ad lib
Yes, let's wear Ludens sunglasses a little at Aid [Music] Yes
cocco Good, do you have a
little eye-
catching?
Let's match this Yes This is a
pair of sunglasses in collaboration with jf 0 Yes
How about raising it
?
This is Norman. The hat looks good.
Oh yeah,
I'm gonna fall in love.
[Music]
I'll count them all
together.  I'm saying it's a decent washbasin, but
I'd like you to change the color vividly. I can change the color a
little, so let's support it a little.
It's going to change to him. It's the one who changed the color earlier
. It's more durable and it's better at that
corner and it's
hard to slip. Please push it a
little. Well, I have only three thoughts here, but the
color  Let's change
this color oc Wear this color Akanishi Hatto Wear
sunglasses
[Music]
What color do
you want to
make it cheap?
Let's go with this Firth
[Music]
I'm going to look good on Akao
Ah
[Music]
Go to the washroom I'm going to the
east and west cg Why
do you put everything in
?  It's something
[Music]
Femchocolat Amazing exe This is
Norman, isn't it
? Hotel
Hmmmm How many likes is
this?
Let's take a as well. By all
means, it's a tie bib, and
next is something in the
back. There's a
nature terminal in the back now
.
There are various menus here. The
order
is the main mission that the player is ordering.
There are other missions,
but the one who listens to the slaves of it and knows all the stages.
Yes, it's
this game. When you meet various people and
stuff them up, you'll get an email. You'll get an email on your
device during the game
, and it's nice to see it in that game. You can pull out this private loan
, but open it a little more.
Please
, there are only 3 people in the Nater Valley Girl. Well,
I get a
thank-you email or money, but
there are also people who order the email here
.
What is the person who says
But he brought me beer,
so now the beer is on the table Yes
, I think there is a star next to the name of that heart,
but
the more star marks there are, the higher the intimacy.
As I went up, the relationship between the prefectures improved
and I was able to do various things.
I like this, but the opening of the data is
[music].
It will be accumulated
,
so if you look at this, please take a look at the restaurant Dino
world view. There are
quite a
lot of things written on
it, so I think that this kind of soup is looking in that direction
.  No, I don't want to read it or explain the terms
, right? There are a tremendous number of
these,
and
one is included,
it's called a bridge link.  You can understand the relationship with those people better
. Well, it's a board. This relationship with
people. If there is a person who wants to deepen the relationship by looking at it, it
's possible to make a strand contract, so
it's not a friend but a strand
lesbian.  Or is it just like that good thing happens
?
This is a music player.
That person has something in
it, and the number of songs is increasing here. Now, that song or
me.
Mitsuo Silent after the object with only 3 trays
And Gen Hoshino
I sleep with a bullet loan in the direction of
rar But it's a no-manner ad lib Yes Yes Yes I'm
knitting more than that and I'm
stopping today  But there's already a space between the stars on the back, so I
'm young after drinking juice.
It feels like I'm a little good at acting
.
Bon is moving. It's
a delusion with Mt. Apo.
This is a good girl in Belgium.
This isn't this one, but at the very end, I
'll introduce you again
.
I
hate it, but I hate it, but
I get sleepy a
8 Change clothes  I'm sure I
'll connect with the baby, and the memory of b will flow backwards
. I'll definitely come in.
[Music]
Here
you can make Cliff Matsu-san
[Music]
Here,
that
Matsu fan  I think it's going to break up a
lot, right? Every time I flash back,
I can see if I'll wait a lot, so it's hard for me to wait.
Yeah
, it's fun for a moment when you grow up
[Music]
Kanpoi Beer and
Ooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooo  I hope you enjoy it
. You can see what it is by pasting it a lot
and solving the game.
That's right, it makes sense.
Well, this is what I set up in such a wasteland.
I'd like to show you that you can customize it by yourself.
Strengthening the building This is to raise the
level. If you want to fry at level 1 to see,
you can put various pictures here to raise the
level.
Even if it's
built by a person, it will be leveled up by another person's entry
.  It's a command to repair going by mouth,
so it melts when I
leave it. Well, everyone is worried,
but I don't think there will be a lot of followers at the venue.
I want to keep this over time.
I think
I have to keep using it. Void I'll customize it. I can play
music. I
showed this to me
.
I
'm a customer, thank you for your hard work.
Buehler It's equipped with the voices of various characters,
and it's increasing and increasing.
I
'm so happy
that I can put it in a [music] I'm so happy that I can put it in
. Why should I do this at first?
Welcome girl Yes
.
And the
last thing is, yes, I can show
that I should stop doing this for a while, so I
can show it most at one mountain
.  It's
okay if you show the party color,
but it will disappear from the world's best of the people who showed it.
If it becomes a record, it will not disappear with other people
.
It's
possible to erase what you're trying to build with this, so I'm
afraid you'll be worried about the non-seat.
I'll connect I'll
go ahead of myself and there's no equipment I've
changed When I first look back at the saplings, I see your equipment there, and for that matter, I control it programmatically here
depending on the player's playstyle and flags.
It
's not a
big deal because there is a referee who said that if you buy it half a year after its release, for example,
you can play
it normally.  I wasn't worried about
that, so after I was happy, my doubts were
resolved at once. Then,
it looks
like this. There is a magnetic field.
Yes, so I
think there is no example of what
he said.  I didn't want to show
it too much because I took off the veil a while ago because there is no building,
but there are many people who say that it's a roof, so let's push it a little
.  I ca
n't do it because it's not in the Showa era, so it's not natural in the front of the facility or at the facility.
It's
a 6-point volmedia that cares
a little more around here.
[Music]
no
I think it's natural to try to see this with a camera
Yes It's impossible to raise it on the wall even if it goes up
Yes Yes Of
course
this is also a property of course, but
is it like this
[Music]
version
There
are a lot of stuff, mother
and mushrooms are fast. People all over the world
can see this.
No matter who pees here, if you
pee on it, the number of sounds will increase
and it will become louder.
But when you see it over your back, Mara Sniper Mountain
Yes, it's not a boundary, it's drowning over there
.
That over is the toughest and most interesting
place, but it's a place where you can go
.  You can do it in the hi-fi ward,
but I said a little bit, so
if you pull it out, it's like a
hot spring. It's a different hot spring 8 seconds ago
. It's a different hot spring, but
yes.  Because it's a little regrettable costume for 4 races,
can you melt the sign a little? It may
be a pee pc, so it's
not possible
.
It's nice to have a sound like
this. Hot springs This is a creator's response. The
function to restore the place of gastrointestinal recovery is also the owner's 3rd place
.  Yeah, yeah yeah I'd like to tell you the
example song today in the to the sun
version.
Well, it was a Norman song before, but I
'm looking at it for a moment
.
I'll buy it if I hit something.
Let's zoom in
. I'm trying to avoid rice. Yeah, I
can't see it
.
Yes, I press the communication
button once.
Shibui is Napa or Tsuda-san.
Synthetic
I'm still recovering from more hands of match Boon
[Music] A
store that is often called
Yes This is good I got a lot of
love hands as it is High
Tsuda-san's version of Wagon Baba is the reason
.
It's like this today
Yes me Dabo  Gray
[Music]